When my little brother Lucas was born,...
...my parents were told that he wouldn't walk or talk...
...and the doctors even said he might not make it to his 10th birthday.
But today, a few months away from his 10th birthday,...
...we're doing our 15th triathlon together.
About four years ago, our boys started doing triathlons together.
In most cases, that wouldn't be a big deal, a lot of kids do triathlons.
But there's something very special about the way our boys do triathlons.
I wanted to do this because Lucas can't do things like we can.
He can't really play sports so this is something we could do together.
Currently we're training for our 15th triathlon, which is this weekend.
Before the race, I always feel nervous.
I don't think I'll ever get over that and I just don't want to hurt Lucas.
I don't care if I win the race, he just has to be okay.